been a little bit more mindful on like
her needs you know like i'm so stubborn
because of
you know how you know how frugal i am
[Laughter]
can i just tell this one story oh tell
it tell it
just just think about your words we can
cut it out if it's not if
you don't want it yeah just really think
about it because there's already a lot
out there
yeah it doesn't help me like because
jeremiah keeps saying it too
it's just so funny well you know it's
the funniest thing i've ever seen in my
life oh yeah go ahead go ahead
you were like it's not malicious bob
collette let's go to the arclight on me
bobby and i could not have sprung from
our chairs any faster we were like holy
[ __ ] steve is treating us to a movie
so we go to the ark like he actually
pays right
and then he's like oh i'm just gonna go
back to your place with you guys after
the movie
and i'm just gonna clean around and
stuff like that i was like steve is
gonna
do a movie and clean our house did i ask
for money
no you took it out of my piggy bank
a pig he fixed i must have been really
struggling back then you were you were
struggling but yeah i am so sorry i did
that
that is so inappropriate how many how
much did he take
i don't know if the movie was 80.
i'm just lit in my defense i haven't
done that in a long time you know which
piggy bank right
oh how could i forget
oh and offered to take people did you
front the money and then you came back
i was just i was just man i needed i
just needed to survive
like that's okay because you know i've
worked like
regular jobs coffee bean and tea leaf
circle okay uh jamba juice
i i could go down the list of you know
i've done the whole thing the blue
yeah i understand that's why i'm so like
stoked that
you know this like you know we get to
make money on content now
i just want to normalize this for you
for a minute from my heart i i want you
to look at me in my eye
i used to do that too like meaning
that even when i was with bobby i worked
like
three [ __ ] jobs like i worked at
starbucks
at the bakery called sweet lady [ __ ]
jane
i worked every [ __ ] day sweating
bobby would be like quit one i was like
no you know what i mean like i just i
was like i have to get my own [ __ ]
but bobby the piggy bank would put money
in this piggy bank
like just take just take money you know
what am i so every day i just
do my [ __ ] chubby little arms in
there take out money
yeah yeah and you get canadian dollars
sometimes
yeah you know when i felt the most
shameful i was working at fat cells
and what bobby's and then i was
in the kitchen and i remember i had to
do the walk of shame because like my
manager's like i think your brother's
here and i had my apron on
and i just remember like having to walk
out there
but man that was a hard job i had a bag
meat i was washing dishes
i almost lost my fingernails